atender el problema de raíz en su
reunión en ciudad de guatemala el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador y su homólogo guatemalteco
alejandro giammattei acordaron cooperar
en proyectos de desarrollo en cada uno
de sus países como una estrategia para
frenar el flujo migratorio desde
centroamérica hacia el norte
no
podemos enfrentar
el fenómeno migratorio compuestos
fronterizos únicamente o con leyes más
severas
o con muros y policías sino con
bienestar con seguridad y paz
un objetivo conjunto por lo que los
mandatarios se comprometieron a
colaborar en programas que ataquen a la
pobreza la inseguridad y la violencia y
que generen empleo y desarrollo y
seguiremos trabajando fuertemente en la
relación tanto con el gobierno federal
como gracias a su gestión con los tres
gobernadores de los estados limítrofes
con guatemala desde el palacio nacional
guatemalteco sede del encuentro lópez
obrador hizo un llamado a eeuu
criticando la falta de la asignación de
dineros para el desarrollo de los países
centroamericanos una situación que
contrastó con las ayudas económicas
brindadas rápidamente ucrania vamos a
seguir insistiendo respetuosamente en la
necesidad de la colaboración
de eeuu
más allá del fenómeno migratorio estoy
convencido de que
este continente debe avanzar nuestra
américa toda américa hacia una
integración económica y comercial
sin exclusiones
al margen de diferencias ideológicas
persiguiendo la meta de ordenar el flujo
migrante en centroamérica exacerbado
durante tiempos de pandemia lópez
obrador se dirigirá a sus próximas
paradas el salvador honduras belice